everyone loves to argue whether gaming
is better on consoles or pcs but let's
be honest it really comes down to
personal preference but if you haven't
given PC gaming a chance
you really should free from the shackles
of brand identity and oversight the PC
as a platform creates an ecosystem
defined by freedom first and foremost it
harbors innovation and experimentation
in apart from the associated cost of
powerful hardware and the desire for
console exclusive games there's no
reason why you shouldn't invest a little
cash and take the plunge into the world
of PC gaming why exactly for starters
there are more games available on PC
than there ever will be on our
traditional console PCs are backwards
compatible with games that are years if
not decades old granted it takes know
how to overcome some operating system
and compatibility issues for which the
Internet at large is a great resource
but there's nothing stopping you from
playing most of the thousands of games
released on PCs over the last thirty
years or so
you've potentially got a lifetime supply
of games at your fingertips the PC is at
large and open development platform
developers have access to a wide
selection of tools with which to create
the game of their dreams and there's no
governing bodies standing in the way of
their vision everyone's free to create
disturbing confusing and profoundly
political games of that's what they want
there are some quality control checks in
place when a game is considered for
distribution on Steam but it's about
stability not conformity if they want
developers can also skip the likes of
steam altogether and publish their game
completely independent of a third-party
distribution service not that they'd
want to but the point is they can
there's no platform that's more open to
technical and artistic experimentation
than the PC and as good as that is for
developers the resulting variety of
games to choose from ultimately benefits
consumers plus it's easier than ever for
the player to double as a developer if
they want to get something new out of an
existing game do you want to play Grand
Theft Auto with the powers of Ironman no
problem add enough of Skyrim's dragons
swap them out with Macho Man Randy
Savage you're all set
user-generated content continues to grow
in popularity and developers are getting
better at giving people the tools they
need to create add-ons and mods for
their games but the ubiquity of said
tools and their potential is greatest on
PC with valve Steamworks pipeline
accessing and sharing mods is easier
than ever before speaking of valve its
steam summer sale just wrapped up and
one who dared to open their eyes and
wallet probably ended up buying a few
more games and they reasonably need why
because so many great games are cheap to
the point that it would be silly not to
buy them
maybe game X wasn't attract about $20
because you weren't sold on its premise
or gameplay but when that same game is
$5 the risk of investment wanes and
you're more likely to take a chance
the allure of low-risk purchases can
lead to a backlog scenario that many PC
gamers are all too familiar with but
that's not necessarily a bad thing to be
fair there are often sales on console
games too but there are barriers to
accessing those discounts most of the
time you have to belong to your premium
subscription service like PlayStation
Plus or Xbox Live Gold to get these
discounts but also to play games online
unless you're talking subscription-based
mmo's you're free to play online
multiplayer PC games free of charge in
nearly every case in terms of hardware
consoles or static products the hardware
inside apart from maybe the hard drive
will never change simply because you
want it to PCs are great because
ultimately you're in control of how
powerful your machine is maxing out a PC
can be costly if you need to be on the
cutting edge but it's not an
all-or-nothing game you can upgrade your
PC piece by piece and sense the price
performance ratio scales with time you
won't have to drop a huge sum of money
in one fell swoop to keep up with the
capabilities of consoles massive gaming
laptops still exist but with the likes
of razor's blade and blade pro we're
beginning to see a shift and it's
possible to carry a device that's more
powerful than a console with its own
screen in your backpack now I still have
console gaming as it exists today but I
appreciate it for very different reasons
than I do PC gaming for now there are
reasons to argue for both sides of the
pc vs consoles of 8 but if you've shied
away from pcs in the past because
they're not immediately user-friendly
consider giving PC gaming a chance for
the sheer variety of games to choose
from in the openness of the hardware and
you may find yourself pleasantly
surprised but everything that the
platform has to offer